There is far more to Izalith than what we've covered on this channel.
"Go back, forbidden be these paths
the realm of the creatures of chaos.
They accept their banished fate."
This isn't just a place that was twisted by the birth of chaos.
This is a place that embraced it and birthed a unique culture in the process.
Within its walls is a tortured family, yes, but one that is far more whole than we ever gave them credit for.
A civilization that went to war with the wider world,
One that may have even made a pact--a truce with their enemies.
"Those who defy the pact, those who trespass Quelaag's domain,
May you feel the depth of our wrath."
There is so much left to discover and not just in the cut content,
but in the translations of these games.
This video is actually almost entirely based upon the theories of
Hawkshaw, who is another youtuber who is one of the first to portray demons in a far more
Civilized and cultured light. It also features
Heavily the translations of Loki, a talented writer who has contributed some of his own theories on top of Hawkshaw's.
We start, of course, with Izalith. The witch of Izalith,
One of the four Lords who found an ineffable soul from the first flame, is actually just named
Izalith in the Japanese text.
There is a point where Quelana simply refers to her as mother Izalith,
And the developers often used terms like "Izalith's children" when talking about the witch in interviews.
The city was still named after her,
But, as those who knew the witch as simply Izalith dwindled, so too did use of her name.
Now this second point I'm going to make pretty much forms the entire foundation for this video.
This is our claim:
It was Izalith's ambition--not her desperation--which led to the creation of the chaos flame.
It's a very commonly held assumption that the witch of Izalith
To duplicate the first flame in an effort to replace it and while it is a fact that she did duplicate the first flame
It's incorrect for us to assume that she did this to replace the fading first flame in
Truth the Japanese only really claims that the witch attempted to create the fire not
Replace it and it's far more likely that the witch in fact
Simply wanted a fire of beginning for herself in addition
Whenever sources talk about this recreation of the first flame they don't mention
Iizalith devotion to Gwynn's age of fire
They don't mention her having this fear of a fading flame
They reference her ambition and as we'll explore
It makes way more sense for the chaos flame to be a failed product of Izalith ambition early in the age of fire
rather than this late product of
desperation when the age of fire was fading
More proof of her ambitions may well be surrounding the ruins of lost Izalith
I'm talking about the lower halves of Dragons
The Japanese name is that which fails to become which is a parallel to all the other.
Serpentine creatures that failed to become dragons
and It's more evidence that Izalith attempted to recreate an ancient dragon
Which is something that many other characters in the series ended up trying to do, and it's pretty much a hallmark of the most ambitious
characters of the series
When Izalith ambition did push her to create a first flame?
She eventually lost control of it and became the bed of chaos
In Quelana's japanese dialogue instead of saying that they turned into deformed creatures
She actually says that her mother and sisters were
Transformed into a seed bed of grotesque life
This of course leaves very little doubt that the bed of chaos is fused with Izalith
at least two of her daughters and
Not only are these two daughters fused with the mother
It's also likely that they helped to bring chaos under control at its core chaos is
Parasitic its creatures are commonly this merging of two beings
But that's not to say that chaos has complete control over its host
In fact the bed of chaos may well be an example of this
First let's establish that each side of the bed of chaos is a daughter of chaos and then will establish that they are helping to
control chaos
When we breach each side notice how we walk through this mass of bright orange runes
These are runes that are shared with the other children of chaos such as Quelaag and Ceaseless
Extending upwards from here are these long straight staffs
which are very much like the Izalith staffs that are wielded by the daughters of chaos in the opening cutscene and
Two staffs in particular are held by each of the daughters on either side of the witch here
After we sever a link the avatar of chaos breaks free and it
Lords over this feminine mother figure who has been feebly swatting us away this whole time
So if the avatar of chaos can break free of its bonds, then it logically follows that Izalith and her two daughters
Brought chaos under control in the first place and Miyazaki says as much in his design works interview when he says that Ceaseless Discharge
Was born when the chaos flame was still not stable and again
What logically follows is that the chaos flame did stabilize at some point?
All of this it really helps us immensely when we're trying to set up a timeline
because it suggests that there are stages to the chaos that erupted in Izalith there was the cataclysmic creation of the chaos flame and
And there was a period afterwards where the flame became somewhat stable
Ceaseless is our proof. He's a demon that was created closer to chaos than anyone
And it's clear that he is far more afflicted as a result our next claim that follows
Is that the first demons that came after ceaseless were born of a more stable flame?
And that this allowed for these creatures to be a little bit more sentient. Let's talk about fire sorceries
Pyromancy and the demons associated with it with the birth of chaos came chaos
pyromancy
and then there was pyromancy after that but before that there were fire arts which were sorceries and
There were also the sorcerers that mastered them in the english text the demon fire sage is said to be at once
The last master of the original fire arts and also the first demon
However, this can't quite be true can it?
We just established that ceaseless was born while the chaos flame was still unstable
So how could the game be stating that this sage is also the first demon consider instead the Japanese text?
Japanese is often really vague when it's talking about whether something is singular or plural and we have run into this problem before
so instead the description could be read as the fire priests of demons were among the first demons and
among the last users of fire sorceries and the demon fire sage himself is actually more accurately a
Fire priest of demons which is a far more fitting name for not just this demon
But this type of demon and for there to be fire sages or fire priests at all
It's a way more convincing argument for this rich culture that Izalith developed
after the mother forced some control over chaos
after all
Pyromancy is one of the most important things that Izalith brought to the world and it only happened as a result of the chaos flame
Dark Souls 3 Izalith staff states that with the birth of the chaos flame the flame witches were at once both sorcerers and
Shamans they weren't obliterated by chaos
They were just changed by it and their fire arts appear to have acquired this element of faith
Which may well be related to these demonic fire priests
Which may well have later become pyromancy
So continuing on from pyromancy the English text claims that Quelana is the mother of pyromancy
And that Izalith is the godmother of pyromancy
But the Japanese text actually uses the same term for both these women calling them founders or pioneers of pyromancy
The word founder is also used for Seif who is the founder of sorcery the Izalith
Pyromancy tome goes on to state that chaos pyromancies led to all later forms
So surely the daughters of chaos were all intrinsic to the development of this pyromancy
Possibly Dark Souls 3 does support this the white hair talisman says that the witches of chaos were founders of pyromancy
So for Quelana to be so versed in pyromancy did she really escape
Immediately after her mother and sisters were turned into the bed of chaos because that's the way she always made it sound
Quelana talks a lot about the anguish of her family
How she escaped and how they need to be freed from chaos, but all other evidence
Suggests that she at least helped them struggle with the initial outburst of chaos, and I don't think it's possible
She just sees them as mere monsters
Quelana robes are actually dressed upon a corpse which is upon an altar in front of her brother Ceaseless Discharge
which suggests that she faked her death to escape because Wiles with this corpse be upon an altar and
Why would you fake your death to creatures that you think are just base monsters the answer is that she can't have left immediately?
Because ceaseless cares about his sister as his rage
Clearly shows because when you desecrate her corpse and steal the robes off of it. That's when he attacks
No, it's very likely that these two had a connection built after the chaos engulfed Izalith after all it was his
elder sisters plural who had sympathy for him and
Attempted to ease his pain with an orange charred ring
There is room for a really really tragic story about Quelana and the legacy that she left behind
But this isn't the video for it so remember to subscribe if you want to see it someday
So as you should be able to tell from this point that there is a far stronger argument for an organized
Intelligent demon culture than there is against it
I'm gonna rattle off a bit more evidence though first becoming a demon may have been something of an optional process
The exception being Izalith and Ceaseless all of whom were brought into being when the chaos flame was still unstable
So consider Quelaag and the fair lady who are not described as among the first demons like Ceaseless 'as
Quelaag strokes her abdomen affectionately in the cutscene showing no resentment for what she's become the fair lady
apologizes to her sister for the death of her eggs
Displaying this desire for demon kind to grow the agama fuge states that egg bearers chose to serve the flame of chaos
Chaos servants can even access a secret path that makes travel more convenient and many demons
Sacrifice humanity in order to serve chaos not just the humanity of others of course like Quelaag does
but many of these creatures might have been humans beforehand the Capra and Taurus demons actually drop humanity and
The Capra demon has the intelligence to train the beasts that serve it
Miyazaki has even gone on record praising the Capra demons design saying that this goat head has this
Sense of ceremony and long-held tradition
There is even a hierarchy among demons almost a monarchy lesser demons greater demons fire
priests Prince's a king
And you might even want to call Izalith the Queen
there is a language a script there are ancient smithing techniques as shown by the chaos flame ember and
Also Quelana who is a daughter of Chaos who is closer to the bed of chaos than anyone?
And yet she shows no signs of transformation after the initial engulfment
Transformation may well have been less about proximity and more about choice
demons are not simple monsters in anguish as Quelana would have us believe and
Were it not for the war that Gwyn waged upon them
perhaps demon kind would have a far better foothold on the world than when we
Encountered them this war against the demons is referenced in the Black Knight weapons
Which were forged to counter the tremendous size of their demonic
Adversaries and it's clear that Izalith was on the losing side of this war
Considering that the Japanese text refers to the city as the obsolete capital of chaos all
This said though demon kind wasn't completely obliterated the capital is again only referenced as
Obsolete it's no longer a threat to humanity or Gwynn's age of fire
It's just this broken civilization. That's devoid of humans and quietly incubating its next generation
Through the egg bearers therefore words from Quelaag cut dialogue about the demons seems likely to remain true
Quelaag also speaks of a pact
Those who defy the pact those who trespass Quelaag acts domain may you feel the depth of her rough
The gods bowed out of the war with the demons in a really dominant position. That's for sure
They were even able to swell their own ranks with demon kind placing them in key positions
The lesser bat winged demons for example wield lightning and very key messengers around the kingdom of the god
and the fiercest demons were just left to fulfill their nature guarding and
executing unwanted undead from those kept in the asylum of Dark Souls one
To those trapped in the undead settlement of Dark Souls 3 it's also quite likely that
When Gwyn bowed out of the war against the demons it might have been because he had a more pressing concern than a drawn-out war
there was the rise of another culture that is far more chaotic than even demons were the
Abyss if this video is received well
Then there is room for a video on them as well for
Now I'm going to direct you to hawk Shores video on demons which offers quite a few more unique theories than have been
Presented here, but anyway
I'm really glad for the opportunity to get everyone up to speed on this channel about how demons are more of a cultured force
So thank you for watching
Finally let's talk one last time about discord about a week ago. We had this huge PvP tournament where thousands of you guys
Competed in the arena for prizes and attempted to kill me in the end only three people got the best of me
And I managed to kill 16 people so it's a pretty good win-loss ratio
Discord Channel was crazy active and it pretty much has been for the last few weeks
So please come and join our community be a part of the growth of not only our channel
But the best voice chat program on the market Fox Co
Also there might be a few impromptu PvP tournaments coming up
Which you can only get in on if you join also for patrons. I'm gonna do one for you guys as well
That's just open to our private discord
So thanks again for watching this video guys go and check out Hawkshaw go and check out discord, and I'll see you next time